tout d'abord comme nos collègues l'ont
fait le groupe démocrate a une pensée
émue pour la jeune agricultrice décédée
ce matin pour son conjoint et sa fille
qui sont dans un état grave nous
adressons toutes nos pensées à leurs
proches ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
Bruno Le Maire et concerne la question
des négociations commerciales qui
impactent directement nos
agriculteur monsieur le ministre comme
vous le savez il nous reste 7 jours 7
jours pour aboutir aux négociations
commerciales entre les distributeurs et
les industriels c'est donc le moment
d'agir monsieur le ministre d'être
auprès de nos entreprisees de nos
agriculteurs et de contrôler massivement
nos distributeurs et certains
industriels qui régulièrement ne
respectent pas la
loi nos agriculteurs sonnent l'alarme
ils sont les victimes d'un modèle
économique qui les dessert porté par nos
grands distributeurs ils sont victimes
d'une course au prix le plus bas d'un
partage de la valeur qui n'est pas
équitable or un agriculteur sur 5 vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté 5 € de l'heure
c'est ce que gagne en moyenne un
agriculteur exploitant si nous voulons à
l'avenir manger français la question du
revenu agricole est centrale nous avons
un patrimoine à conseré et l'agriculture
la plus durable du monde si la
transition agroécologique doit se mener
activement elle atteint coût les
agriculteurs ne doivent plus être la
variable
d'ajustement la loi Galim a pour
objectif de sanctuiriser les matières
premières agricoles si ces dernières
années nous avons pu constater des
améliorations dans les échanges cette
année dans une grande partie des
négociations ce n'est pas le
cas alors monsieur le ministre en
novembre dernier vous aviez annoncé une
mission gouvernementale afin de
travailler en profondeur le sujet dans
l'immédiat j'aimerais savoir quelles
actions vous comptez mettre en place
pour répondre à la souffrance de nos
agriculteurs je vous
remercie